five screenplays based on material from
another medium have been nominated I can
appreciate the task of adapting a work
from another medium because I am
struggling right now to write a
screenplay from my own novel Passion
Play I deplore that the origin author
was not more inventive for their success
I congratulate most warmly these
nominees Harold Pinter for the French
Lieutenant's woman Ernest Thompson for
on Golden Pond Dennis Potter for pennies
from heaven
Jay Preston Allen and Sidney Lumet for
Prince of the city
and Michael Weller for ragtime
now for the winner the winner the winner
is
Ernest Thompson
I wrote on Golden Pond as a play four
years ago for two reasons first I was
out of work as an actor and second
because I believed that I had something
to say and a burning need to say it I
want to thank a few people who believed
in me as a writer before it became
popular to do so this won't take very
long dick Koh Steve Sheeran Jim Prideaux
George Shaffer and Patti McCormack who
has given me so much I want to thank my
family for its support I wish the hell
my father was alive tonight I want to
thank my producers Jane Fonda Bruce
Gilbert Martin stager Lord grade for
believing in this project and believing
in believing me when I said I thought I
could write a screenplay I want to thank
my director MOC Rydell for being so damn
difficult to satisfy and I want to thank
an incredible company of actors for
making my word sound so intelligent and
funny from Franny Sternhagen and Tom
Aldridge who first said them in New York
on stage to Kate Hepburn and dear Henry
and Jane and all the actors have spent
time on Golden Pond from my heart thank
you and I want to thank the Academy for
this great great honor I am so proud and
if you would all see me later I would
love to suck face with you all
you